[Music]
hello welcome welcome to this early
morning session today we are going to
talk about operating severus apps and
function we start over with Google's tag
driver
I am stearin I'm a product manager on
cloud currently working on all severus
products actually before that I built
take over all reporting
good morning thanks everybody who braved
the Thursday morning after the party and
made it to the session my name is J Jud
coats I'm in product management for
stackdriver have a long career starting
with back in high T in the late 90s and
so I've always been very fascinated with
you know how we make things better more
available and so we're very excited to
bring that knowledge and awareness for
that Google's built up and bring it to
serve with sapsucker stackdriver
so quick agenda first stern is gonna
give a good overview of server lists
why serverless matters what our runtime
choices are at Google and how to pick
one and then why monitoring and service
lists can be hard at times we're gonna
switch over to me and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about what Google has learned
from its 20 years in the business and
particularly the sre discipline which
we're trying more and more to bring in
the stack driver and then we'll bring
that all together we'll talk about how
sre knowledge works in stackdriver for a
server list and will understand Mo's
with the whole thing and not just two
slides Thank You Jay
so what is 7s you might have attended
some some other sessions about it let me
recap today the few characteristics that
we use to define severus products on
Google cloud the first one is that a
service product is for developers users
of the 7s product focused on delivering
business value focus on code the
provider takes care of the rest
this is a key characteristic the second
one is that it scales it scales to zero
which means if you don't use it
- slowly scale down to zero but if you
use it a lot potentially it scales with
you so really there is no provisioning
to do in advance nothing no management
of number of instances this is done for
you automatically the sound
characteristics that it is managed
so by managed of course the cloud
provider is taking care of the
infrastructure for you is taking care of
the updates of this infrastructure of
the reliability of this infrastructure
but also of the security and we provide
a lot of security features for our
service products out of the box so
managed security to the last point is a
billing model you really pay for what
you use so because it scales because we
have this operational model where it
scales up and down following your
traffic your needs we are able to
provide you a dealing model where you
only pay when you use it so as a
consequence you know don't need to you
know commit to a certain message in
advance you do not need to provision a
certain cluster size no no it's all
based on what you need a so at a certain
point in time and you will only pay for
that if you take those characteristics
you can see how it applies to more than
just small snippets of code in the cloud
more than just functions if you take
those definition you can see that we can
apply these to many areas like database
like storage like AI like data
processing all of these Google cloud has
products that we qualify to be several s
because they answer those definition
those points so you can see you know on
the data storage side when project are
really recommend that is a great pair
with we stablished compute is a cloud
data store on the file storage side we
have clouds
storage perp sub cloud ml engine a big
query all of these you do not have to
care about the infrastructure you didn't
you really pay when you use it so all of
these are what we qualify 7s for this
talk we are going to focus on several s
compute so today or two generally
available product in Google cloud that
we that are several is compute our cloud
functions that we announced to be
generally available yesterday and App
Engine that has been here for a while
and loved by many many customers so
these are all to several s compute
product and recently we introduced a new
a newcomer in this picture which is the
the gke severus add-on so here to be
clear the gk server is add-on allows you
to get a several s developer experience
within your own kubernetes cluster but
it does not provide you the several s
economics however all of the other
attributes are available for this
product so this is it has been announced
yesterday and is currently in alpha so
this this is the severest compute
picture of our graph cloud now I'm going
to help you a little bit picking between
these because I can acknowledge this
might not be easy some time and well the
first one cloud functions as the name
says the unit is the function so here
you are going to really think about not
something that does many purposes but
only one thing so it's really well
tailored for single purpose micro
services and because you can trigger a
function not only via HTTP but also via
events it will be a good fit when you
want to do a synchronous workloads or
things that react after something in
your cloud architecture has triggered so
everything is that is event days and
async are our good use case for cloud
functions regarding event triggers we
keep adding more and more
you can you know to mention a few you
can you can trigger a function when
something of course when there is an HTP
request coming in but also when for
certain logs for pub/sub events when
there is a database change like recently
we announced the availability of cloud
file store
vents for cloud functions you can
trigger a function when there is a new
file in cloud storage so really many
many events and we are going to keep
adding more over time
this is cloud function the second
product I mentioned is App Engine so App
Engine the unit here is an application
so an application will be source code
that you deploy and and deploy to App
Engine the workloads that you deploy to
App Engine are triggered via HTTP so
that means that HTTP coming from the
outside world so if you for Apple you
are going to create a mobile API or just
a website with a with with a front-end
and multi-purpose website then the App
Engine is a very good fit also those
HTTP requests are coming from the inside
so you might have an architecture with
many services and services talking to
each other and they they obviously can
use HTTP to do that so it engine will be
best used when you migrate an existing
code base because as we've announced
yesterday
we now have what we call the App Engine
second generation runtimes and those are
what we say idiomatic so what does that
means that you can take any module on
your favorite programming language and
bring them on App Engine and it's all
savelist so if you are a node.js
developer you can use any npm modules
from any modules from NPM
be it regular one or a native one like
something that uses binary code you can
do it on App Engine stand out now and we
announced recently the ability of Python
3 and PHP 7 on App Engine stand out so
also something that really scales down
to zero and scales with you to snapshot
scale Epogen has been here for a while
but if you take the characteristics of
what the severest service is App Engine
is service appengine standard and the
last newcomer is the DK service add-on
so here the unit is the container image
so of course the add-on allows you to
build from source to image but at the
end of the day the things that are
running and scaled or you are continuing
in ages even if you built them from
source using our all tooling so when
would you pick that one you will pick it
when you're coming from a kubernetes
world and you want to give to your
developers in your organization a sever
less experience right developers should
not have to worry about pods and replica
stats and and scaling those parts no no
they just want to deploy code and they
want things like the DES system to
handle the rest and this system is what
the severest add-on gives you so you
would count you take it when you already
have a GK cluster when you want to stay
in it you would pick that when you have
some special needs of resources that App
Engine or cloud functions do not give
you so for example custom VM sizes or
you want to access GPU or you will pick
that for example when you want to be
close to another workload that is
already in GAE
so let's assume you have an elastic
search service running on GAE then if
you want your your server let's walk
loads to be close to it then this would
be a good fit so the DK service add-on
is currently in alpha but all of what we
are going to talk about later apply to
it too so this is a picture of several s
in Google Cloud however there are some
changes monitoring severus the first one
will be that by definition the servers
are not accessible so that means a few
things that means that you don't control
for App Engine and cloud functions you
don't control the OS so if you principle
have to install a particular agent
monitoring agent you can't so that that
presents a challenge also you know
in the past we just ssh into an instance
to see what's wrong well you you can't
include functions or app engine this is
this is not something we will give you
you cannot just ssh the the usual way so
when you see how we provide tools to to
address that then several s encourages
to break the monolith into independently
scalable pieces because obviously if
those pieces can scale up and down to
zero then breaking them into into pieces
will will be a better economics for you
you you know it's each of them we can
scale to zero and you don't need them
that that's what you will be looking for
so as a consequence severus encourages
micro services and micro services mean
that you have more pieces to monitor and
operate and to look to trace between all
of these so we will see how we can help
with that and then the point is auto
scaling as I said a service product
scales with you so when you don't have
any requests there is no instance so
there is nothing to to look to monitor
and when the traffic comes in then
instances are scheduled for you and then
automatically they are stopped when it's
needed also you cannot you know rely on
the fact that an instance will be here a
long time now instances are spin up and
stopped very frequently in severus so
what does that mean is that that means
that first you you you really cannot
look at the instance level you really
should look at the service level the
second is that cold start matter as you
know if instances are started in start
very frequently then you cannot do a lot
of things at startup time so you cannot
load many module mini monitoring agent
when things start and for functions it's
even going one step further which is
that include functions outside of the
execution of the request
you cannot do anything so that means
that you you you you cannot expect to
have CPU outside of the request response
timeframe so that's all
challenge and lastly Severus as I said
allows you to build a synchronous
workloads here for example you can react
to an event you can use a queue to
include some tasks we have cloud tasks
that we release to beta recently you can
use pub sub topics to send events across
your micro services so all of this makes
it harder to see what triggered what in
your micro services
so now we'll see how start over and the
we will see later host a clever can help
you address those challenges Jane thanks
Tara so like I said stackdriver is
really really fortunate to be a part of
Google where we have at our disposal the
whole SRE team to learn from to see how
they you know build Google to where it
is and everybody see the book that they
released in revision 2 just came out so
I definitely encourage that it's really
good reading so what did we learn from
Sree and how are we taking advantage of
that so Google has eight services with a
billion or more users we have 2,500 sres
and the math doesn't really work this
way but that's over 400 thousand users
served per Sree which is incredible
economy of scale and not only that the
the Sree is you have a great culture and
love their work and so this is the thing
that customers have come and said hey
we'd like to be able to have you know a
great ops culture that that scales in
and really takes care of our customers
now to to do this they've had to solve
really one huge trade off on the one
hand reliability Google comm is sort of
synonymous with is my internet up it's
pretty reliable but on the same the
other hand they're trying to figure out
how to keep Google engineers as
productive as possible how can we
experiment
can we release how can we put out new
functionality and as you know change is
the biggest thing that affects
reliability so balancing between those
two things is the main challenge of sre
and why they've developed the culture
they have so I'm not gonna do a whole
sre talk that would be in an hour on it
on its own but I'll say from from the
stackdriver side what have we observed
about sre that's that's special and
different and what are the ingredients
that are needed to pull together so the
first piece is culture s Ari's aren't
running around pager playing
whack-a-mole with problems all day that
that would just not scale and and they
wouldn't be happy either
in fact most most on-call shifts only
result in a couple pages a week what our
series doing then before an incident
they're working on automation right
automating all the monitoring automating
all the data collection automating all
of the you know responses to simple
problems that can be handled without
human intervention
they're also helping the application
developers engineer the reliability into
the product they do the production
readiness reviews they say whether
something is ready to go live at huge
scale they say whether it's really
worthy of having the pager taken by the
SRE team they're also responsible for
when there is an incident the incident
response process we won't talk about
that here but that's that's in the book
it's a really interesting scaleable
predictable system in the face of what
could be chaotic events they're
responsible for the blameless
post-mortems
which are really important because that
is that you're never going to keep
improving reliability and agility if
you're not able to you know look back at
problems and see what caused them
without people being afraid of some kind
of repercussions now the most important
part of what the s eries work on is SL
OS the service level objectives that
drives everything we do and drives how
we think about reliability I'm not going
to describe that here because there's a
slide and a feature it will go into that
in detail and apply that to to the
service products now if you're an SRE
team and you're outnumbered by
over ten to one and and everything
you're doing is data-driven particularly
SLO work
imagine a conversation where you go to
all these engineers and say I want to
get I want you give me this metric this
metric this log this thing that thing
and I want you to do it you know and
keep up with my thinking on how
monitoring should evolve it'd be a short
conversation right it's pretty hard to
get all these people to give you all
exactly what you want so Google what we
did is we bake this into the
infrastructure when a Google developer
deploys a service that service is
well-defined
it's discoverable it has an identity
things like quota and permissions are
config on that system and there's
automatic telemetry exact you know the
same telemetry from every there's a
baseline of telemetry that every service
has that comes from the infrastructure
the developer doesn't have to worry
about this keeps the developers very
productive and it keeps the S Ari's full
of the data that they need and removes a
fundamental tension that could be there
if we weren't careful about that now you
don't know work at Google and don't
develop on Google infrastructure but
we've baked these principles into the
server lists runtimes so functions and
App Engine and the server lasat on the
gke
all return standardized metrics that can
be used in a standardized way in the
stackdriver dashboards that we'll be
showing
we've also open sourced other nifty
things inside Google that are pretty
helpful
so stubby is our secure RPC mechanism
that's open source of G RPC and census
our system for our open source library
for collecting metrics and traces that
is that that's been released as open
census now you cool is a big place and
so if every app is automatically getting
all these signals sent that turns into a
lot of stuff so we have petabytes of
logs every day billions of monitored
resources hundreds of billions of time
series where is that all go well you
need a platform that scales to handle
that
need to be able to store it you know
keep it safe query it do analytics on it
and we're not going to talk about this
it's not the topic of the presentation
but note that that is the bottom half a
stock driver when you use stack driver
you're putting your metrics your logs
your traces and the same robust and
scalable systems that Google engineers
are the last piece and this is where
we're really gonna focus is the tools
it's kind of the tip of the iceberg
right everything that I talked about
before is that giant iceberg under the
water what's above the water is the
tools how do i implement this
operational culture taking advantage of
all this data and doing useful things
and that that's what we're going to go
into detail about and demonstrate for
you is unstack driver front-end so what
tools are available for serverless
from stack driver so what are the
columns first is monitoring this is
basically your metrics whether it's
coming from the infrastructure or custom
metrics coming from the app it could be
uptime checks it could be log counts but
all these metrics are stored there
queryable you can set alerts and
notifications on them create incidents
when they go out of whack and so that's
the the core piece of the expect from
monitoring solution vendors logging an
error reporting logging is you know
collection of logs error reports or
special logs that are tied to stack
traces and oftentimes and you want to do
special analytics on lastly is
application performance management that
is our tracing product distribute trace
we'll talk about our continuous profiler
which helps you manage costs and the
live debugger which lets you figure out
the state of your application down to
the variable level without pausing
redeploying or crashing the app as you
can see green check marks all across the
board for App Engine we've supported
that for quite a long time in fact a lot
of these products supported App Engine
before they supported anything else
cloud functions monitoring logging error
reporting work no question the APM tools
also work but some of the libraries and
instrument
tation need to be optimized for the
function world so I definitely encourage
people to try it out and may or may not
be ready for production for your app
depending your function is depending
lastly gka serverless ad on the
stackdriver team and the serverless
teams are working very very closely to
make sure that these all work by the
time we go to public beta as of the
alpha state it's still in progress
alright so let's look at this in action
so b4 so we're basically we have an
application and that application we're
gonna you know do things to it and the
demos will show how the monitoring
features come into play but staring
wrote this so let's let him describe the
let's see what the app does and then I
will explain you how it's done
so simply this is a website the title is
web page watch so what is web site does
is that it you submitted a URL of a web
page and then it will watch it for
changes visual visual changes so for
example on this test test example ad I
wrote a static web page that you know
from when the button changed color and
as you see my web page watch our website
captured those two what we call
keyframes so there was a change they
were captured visually so let's switch
back to the slides to see how we built
that using several s products so the
first thing to know that every five
minutes there is cloud scheduler which
is going to trigger another service and
the service is what we call all task
scheduler so the task scheduler will
query the database for webpages to watch
so the database will return ok of this
set of web pages and go go watch them
the scheduler for each of those web
pages will create an event in cloud
pub/sub and this event will be take a
screenshot of that page so one event per
screenshot to take this is the only job
of that service the second service has
only one job taking screenshots of the
web page it
it gets so this Auto service is written
in app engine we could have written a
cloud functions for that because both
App Engine and cloud functions support
all of the libraries that you need to
run headless Chrome so this screenshot
service is running Chrome without a
visual interface but it's rendering your
web page taking your screenshot and
that's it that the only job of that
service super simple like literally
hundreds line of code I am not going to
show them but very simple to write one
it once it took a screenshot it will
store it in cloud storage simple and
anytime something is added to that cloud
storage bucket an event is triggered and
this event will trigger a cloud function
this cloud function also has only one
job it's comparing the new file with a
reference file and if there is a
difference it will store the new
screenshot as the new reference and it
will capture it as a keyframe so here if
there is a difference it will keep the
new image that it just received that's
basically what's happening every five
minutes you know this is configurable
with cloud Kaduna and then when I open
my web page watch our website as a user
what I'm doing is I'm hitting a
front-end service that is regular you
know website service that queries of
course the database to look for the web
pages that we are tracking and also when
I look at the details of the of one of
those web pages it will query the cloud
storage to to return the key frames of
that web page so you see for services
for micro services each of them super
super simple but brought together they
are doing something very complex in a
very reliable way and so this is all
demo app and now Jay is going to go over
some the first scenario for monitoring
and troubleshooting this dis app so what
you should know is that I did a release
of that application 30 minutes ago so
let's see if this release is healthy I'm
sure it's gonna be great
so so we're going to talk about two
features that are gonna come into play
in the first demo the first feature is
an SLO feature so this is like I say I
deferred earlier that we're gonna dive
into this s Ari's like I said they don't
chase around you know problems playing
whack-a-mole with pager all day what
they because again that the toil would
be too high and the scale wouldn't be
there what they really worry about is
what affects the customer directly so
let's look at a very trivial example
what if the CPU runs hot well that could
affect a customer but we've done the
obvious automation there we've
implemented auto scaling it scales out
the CPU drops and if there is any
degradation performance it goes away
there's no point paging somebody it it
works right but no matter how much
automation you do no matter how much
thought you put into the system you
always make it better and better but you
never get rid of every last problem and
so at some point there's something you
didn't automate away and it affects the
user and that's what the SL eyes are
about is quantifying the effect to the
user so what does the user care about
did they care about your CPU no not at
all
what did they care about they care about
two obvious examples availability what
percentage of my calls come back with
the 200 response they care about latency
let's say a particular service works
well up to 300 milliseconds response
time so I care what percentage of my
what percentage of my requests come back
to 300 milliseconds are left so those
are indicators those percentages are the
service level indicators now you know
once you know what it is you're watching
and what it does your users care about
you put an objective on that and that
objective is sort of the promise you're
making to yourself whether you
externalize the promise or not saying
this is how I know my thing is working
for example I might want you know 99.9
percent 200 responses or I might want
99% of my calls to come back in under
300 milliseconds now you notice that
nose exam
as I throw out there I didn't use the
number 100 and there's a good reason for
it there are a couple good reasons for
that
one is if you needed a hundred percent
you'd have zero flexibility to do
anything and any change anywhere that
broke anything
would would break your promise so 100
doesn't often make sense but second you
know people are pretty good at writing
apps that are resilient you know you get
it you get a 500 retry probably work you
know Web Services like if you go to a
web page and 99 out of 100 times it
loads satisfactorily in the last time it
doesn't load satisfactorily you'll be
okay right
so having a non hundred percent SLO is
really really important concept
now when you subtract the objective from
a hundred what you're left with is the
error budget that is how many calls
you're allowed to have that you know in
availability case that aren't 200 or in
a latency case that are that are slower
than you'd like and by the way there's
other SL O's and SLI is out there I'm
just going over the most common ones and
the error budget is critical thing s
Ari's really really really focus on this
because if your error budget is is low
or you know below zero
you should stop adding features right
you should start fixing technical debt
you should you know hold off release you
should fix the system make it more
reliable what if the error budget is
super high well you know crank up the
dial to say hey we're not we're not
experimenting enough where we're giving
the users more reliability than they
need and that seems like it would be a
good thing except for two problems one
they could really start relying on that
and you may not be able to maintain that
or two you may not be given the features
they want because your customers want
reliability and they want features so
make it as reliable as they need and
then get as many features in as you can
spend your error budget like your money
budget right and then what if your SLO
is okay like it you haven't broken it
but it's dropping precipitously well
that's when you page somebody if you
have a precipitous drop in error error
budget in an SLO for an indicator that a
customer really cares about that's when
the essary gets woken up at 2 in the
more
now I've grayed out this third concept
SLA because it's not really necessary
concept but it's a business concept and
people ask about it in this context SLA
czar when you give some kind of
guarantee to your customers and some
sort of maybe like I'll give you a
refund if I don't meet this SLO yeah by
and large again like I said not
necessary concept obviously the advice
here is you would if you have an SLO
tied to an SLA you should probably have
a much stricter SLO internally that
you're not publishing because you
certainly don't want your your finance
and legal to be the ones notified the
first time something goes wrong you want
to you want to work really really hard
to keep customer happiness high and then
have your money back gaurantee at a
higher level of dysfunction so feature
number one is going to be that SLO
feature feature number two is an
integrated service dashboard so
stackdriver has a lot of pieces and I
kind of routed them off before and
they're all really awesome and
independently they all add a lot of
value but they're all in different pages
different domains right I have a
dashboard page I have an incident page I
have a log page I have an error report
page a trace page but if I'm monitoring
a particular service what I really want
to know is what are all of the signals
that I have for that one service and put
those all in one place and be able to
have an integrated troubleshooting
experience that goes from I have enough
Salo problem to you know here are my
metrics to here my logs and go deeper
and deeper and so that's what we've put
together so let's do demo one let's have
a bird's-eye view of micro service and
see what's going on here so what we're
looking at is the the screenshot service
you can see the name here here you can
see the timeline I can zoom in to a
particular time we'll show that later in
a demo we have an incident history event
history and like I said we're going to
start with the s loz because the s o
those are what we're managing to like
we're not managing CPU or memory we're
managing
to the SLO and we have an SLO says we
want 90% availability in the last seven
rolling days and as you can see we were
doing pretty well we had a big hiccup
yesterday I guess Stern and I were
practicing the demo I mean we were doing
really well and there was this little
blip not sure what that was but blips
happen it's a small one and we survived
it but something bad is happening right
now right we're definitely not getting
90% we're something like 60% of
successful responses and the error
budget accordingly is is low so that
we've you know we've been playing with
this over the last week and we're under
zero if it really looked like this in
real life
everybody would all hands on deck for
reliability surge but right now you can
see the error budget even though it was
below zero it's dropping even further
and then we could look at the metrics
for the service and say what's going on
here so this is a lot of information
here but what's cool is we have this
group by and filter response a group by
an filter functionality so for example
starin mentioned he did an upgrade right
so let's a group by version ID and we
could so there's now you can see we have
all these different you know we have the
new and the old but there's still a lot
of lines there I just want to know about
the 500 response codes so I can filter
to that response code 500 and and here
we go
so this is the the new one and this is
the old one so like I said the old one
had that one little blip but that's not
bad that went away the new one
is it it it's it's giving us errors and
more and more errors all the time and
this is not good it's burning through
our error budget so you know I could
worry about debugging the code or
whatnot but right now I just want to
roll back so I go over App Engine and I
can go to the old version and I can
migrate all the traffic
and if we come back here we'll find in
you know a minute or two is that will
we'll see the there will see the errors
go down and we'll come back to the SLO
page and we'll see the SL eyes return it
you know going up but for the sake of
you know we can come back to that at the
end you can see already the DSL is
starting to flatten out pretty quickly
so that is the first demo and let's see
what we're gonna do next so features
that are gonna show up in the next demo
include distributed tracing so just by
show of hands who here's use distribute
tracing before No
okay one person awesome okay so we're
going to play for everybody else like uh
Stern said I have if I have
micro-service based application you know
he showed one with like about five
micro-services but what if you have tens
or you know some people have even
hundreds of micro-services if something
is slow why is it slow do you just start
at the front end and try to figure out
all the way back where this loan this is
coming from that'll take you all day
what distributed traces do is they get a
sample they get uh they sample the code
and they basically say okay for this
transaction I'm gonna trace this one I'm
gonna find out how much latency came
from this microservice how much came
from this micro-service how much came
from this microservice and it draws a
picture ties it together into a
waterfall and then you're able to see
just at a glance where's the slow span
and when you look at the slow when you
figure out what your span is a slow one
you can then go into other tools like
we'll talk about next to figure out why
so distribute tracing is a really really
really powerful tool for figuring out
what's wrong with your microservices the
instrumentation for that is open census
and that is a vendor agnostic
instrumentation and we're working with a
lot of our partners and competitors on
this to make sure that when you can get
tracing it's not just tracing for
stackdriver but it's tracing for whoever
so if you switch tools you know maybe as
an ops purse
and you're switching tools and that's
bummer but for the your developers they
don't care they still have senses now
like I said what about why is it slow so
once you figure out which span is slow
you can go to the profiler and the
profiler it tells you continuously also
through sampling which functions in your
code are taking up CPU which ones are
taking up time you could figure out who
your problem child is down to the
function level within the micro service
and so that's a really powerful tool
that's an that we've released recently
so let's look into a performance issue
actually let's see if the so again start
just on the on the last demo well we'll
do it'll come back at the end I just
make sure for time that we so looking at
the where different service now we're at
a default service so on the default
server so you could see again we wanted
less than half a second on 95% of the
calls we were doing good except for our
big test there and again the the the
rollout has caused us a problem here
so we can go into the metrics and see
what's going on and this heat map here
is showing us that this is where the
latency generally was hottest but now
what's up here and if we want to go even
deeper into the more proof again we can
group by filter ID group by version ID
and if I look at the old one that's the
latency I want and if I look at the new
one yeah that's the latency I didn't
want so pretty pretty stark pretty
manufactured demo but you get an idea of
how the tools work and how they show you
this stuff so now again I can go and
solve the fix the problem so I go to the
old you know old and migrate the traffic
back and like I said that'll take effect
in a couple minutes we'll be able to
come back at the end of demo and show
you the updated graphs but you know I'm
not I don't want to rollback I want to
know what the heck happened here so
let's go to the Diagnostics tab and in a
Diagnostics tab we have traces and so
all right this is this this is a thirty
four hundred millisecond trace that's
like seven times what I set the SLI goal
to the objective to right and because
the problem could have been anywhere it
could have been in Stern's code or it
could have been in something he was
calling and if you look here stairs code
and here is all the things he called
well you know like data stores behaving
really nice
there's fetch results functions behaving
really really nice this is not behaving
so nice so this is where we're gonna
focus and figure out so let me call
staring back up and keep telling what
happened there I click diagnose that I
think you know it's probably not Network
related otherwise you would we would see
the span on that on that trace waterfall
so I think this is more code related
let's dive into profiler and try to
understand where where that time goes so
I'm opening sort of a profiler right
here you know to to get it I open it
from the cloud console so this is type
of a profile that you recently released
what you're looking at here is the heap
profile for my application and usually
when I look at such graph you know very
rich graph but you know the patterns I'm
looking at are very long spans that are
at the very bottom because that means
that one thing is taking a lot of time
so here I don't see that but you know
I'm looking at heap profile right here
let's let's go to wall wall clock time
this would be CPU and let's filter out
the what we call the program you know
frames which are basically when my
program is idle so this I want to filter
arts because it's probably when no
requests come in okay and right here you
see there is something that looks
suspicious here there is this very long
span that his name in the function his
name is prime did I just produce to
production something that computes for
prime numbers sorry I was testing things
and I'm sorry
just just double check so I'm doing I'm
going to compare version the old version
yeah this one looks looks like a normal
profile waterfall so this is you know
long span and if I go to the new version
then yes if we look at on the right we
can see like the same kind of CPU usage
but on the majority of our time is spent
computing these prime numbers so I'm
sorry about that I think it's good you
rolled it back and I will remove that
from the code so this is start of a
profiler continuously profiling my app
really without without me having to do
anything so let's switch back so now no
fix that I would open my editor and
simply fix the code itself now going
back to the last demo the tools we will
use in that demo are star driver or
reporting so start off at the error
reporting is automatically monitoring
your logs for some application errors so
for example when there is a crash most
of the time in your logs you will see a
stack trace an exception and so Stiga
in real time is looking at all of your
logs looking for crashes when it finds a
crash it will capture it and when it
finds the same kind of crash it will it
will group them together so that what
you will focus on when you open our
reporting are groups of errors not
single single entries but really they
are grouped meaningfully together so it
is all real time and the way to get it
is simply if we are logging so that
means that on on all our of of 7s
product because you get logging
out of the box you get also error
reporting out of the box and the second
tool I will use in that last demo is
stag driver de Vega so style ever
debugger is an amazing technology I told
you before I'm not able to associate in
my VMs but that doesn't mean I cannot
inspect the state of my instances and
basically what de Vega allows you to do
is to inspect the state of a running
application without slowing it down so
it's not like a breakpoint it doesn't
stop the execution no no it's when you
put a snapshot as we call them it will
snapshot the entire state of the app and
then continue the execution but you will
have visibility into the state of your
application so we have snapshots and we
have one of my favorite feature which is
lock points
so how many times did you just redeploy
a new version just by adding some log
statements because you couldn't figure
out what was running well was wrong on
production right and what debugger lock
points allow you to do are simply to add
a statement dynamically in your code
without having to redeploy because under
the hood we are using the exact same
technology as for snapshots which are
that every time the code will is acute
at that point we will snapshot the state
and we will print a log into a log entry
into your logs so you can dynamically
add a log statement to your code with
that redeploying to set up stack level
debugger you have to import a library
this library when you are not using the
bugger has no impact on your on your app
and when you're using it as very very
low impact so I recommend to import it
in case for the future something needs
to be diagnosed in production so my last
demo will be using a reporting and
debugger to understand an application
error based on an availability allowed
so let's switch to the demo I received
this email from stackdriver
telling me that there's a new era in my
micro service screenshot I could also
have received a push notification if I
if I was using if I was on my smartphone
we have the Google Cloud mobile app and
you receive push the same kind of
notification on your mobile so ok let's
let's click let's click that call to
action viewer details let me understand
what's going wrong here let me zoom in a
little bit to to one hour to see better
okay so there is a new error you see it
happened
37 time in that time frame well
obviously it's not the first time we see
it because we rehearsed but let's see it
was 10 minutes ago I think it was last
seen when Jay rolled back to the
previous version so it seemed that the
error is under control but still I would
like to to diagnose it well actually you
know what let me roll back to the broken
version otherwise the rest of the demo
will not walk this this was this
sorry ok so what you see here are the
details of a given mo group so at the
bottom you have many samples of that
ever you know I can expand I can see the
stack trace and at the top you have a
sample stack trace for that L group and
you see we clean it up for you so we
removed the frames that are the node.js
frames or in that case it's expressed J
s so this is framework code you as a
developer don't want to worry about that
what you want to worry is your code and
this code is in savage a s is my code
alright so something is wrong let's you
know let's let's hit auto reload to make
sure thing yeah you see it start to
happen again when I rolled forward to
that to that new version so let's let's
let's dive it to the code I'm just
clicking that file several j s it opens
tied ever debug view what debug does it
will stay it will automatically set a
snapshot at this point of the code so
you see I did not have to provide my
code because when I deploy to App Engine
I already push my source code so we
Deborah can easily fetch that same
source code and allow you to set
snapshots on that source code so let's
let's wait for the error to trigger or
you know we can trigger it directly by
hitting the screenshot service as you
see it produces an internal server error
and when I do that
okay the snapshot just hit and so it's
room a little bit what you see so the
snapshot was put here at this line and
here I can inspect the variable so I see
that URL is actually undefined well okay
so now I understand better the URL dot
starts with you know you cannot that
obviously cannot be called because the
divine bill doesn't exist is undefined
so that will crash my application so you
know if I wanna double check I can add
more snapshots but at this point I'm
pretty sure but what's going wrong here
so my action immediately I will roll
back to the previous version and I will
fix my code simply by opening my editor
so you see this was live production code
that we inspected and we got the values
of the variables
thanks to stock ever Deb ago that's that
that's the end of all demos let's switch
back to the slides for a recap so the
first thing is that we've shown you a
little bit about the time side of a
suite there are many other things we
haven't shown like alerts but for you to
now sign ever is many tools we
introduced today the start of service
dashboard SLO monitoring that are new
today and profiler was released very
recently then the other takeaway that we
want you to to remember is that
stackdriver
and service on GCP this is a check mark
stack level as all you need to monitor
and troubleshoot your civilized
applications and functions and for a lot
of it it's out of the box
and lastly wink reduce to try it out so
on the civil side we announced in alpha
the the severest add-on for gke you can
request access I think a J you want to
talk a bit more but the early access
program of yep so with the service
monitoring including the SL O's is an
early access there's a Google form to
fill out if you reach out to two reps or
two to start an arai we can get you
access to that
alright so contact it's a Jeju it's my
last name at Google calm and you can
reach out and I can get you access to
the to the survey so you can sign up for
the EAP for service for service
monitoring same for me if you're
interested in the service add on or try
it out on on you newly released runtimes
for 7s it's a steer on at google.com my
first name at google.com feel free to
reach out
[Music]